thumbs up means
well
thumbs up right
but it's not always been that way
[Music]
in the roman era a thumbs up meant death
for a gladiator if the gladiator was to
be spared the referee would press the
thumb to the top of the fist
if he flicked it up it was bad news
there's a common misconception that a
thumbs down meant death back then it's
thought to have stemmed from this
painting by jean leon jerome in 1872
which shows a coliseum crowd with arms
outstretched and thumbs pointing to the
ground he got it wrong
it's thought the positive meaning of
thumbs up started with english archers
in the middle ages a fist with thumb up
measured the correct brace height of the
longbow
so the gesture came to mean all is well
ready for battle
another origin of the gesture comes from
merchants in medieval times
they would seal a deal by licking their
thumbs and pressing them together
so a thumbs up came to mean done deal
allied fighter pilots in world war ii
used the gesture to indicate
chocks away
when they were ready for takeoff and
it's thought that american gi spread the
gesture throughout europe even today
italians call it the american okay
hitchhikers around the world hope to
thumb a lift from passing traffic but
watch out in greece sardinia in the
middle east where a thumbs up sign is an
insult and is more likely to get you
into trouble than the next town
when a scuba diver gives a thumbs up it
means it's time to swim back to the
surface this signal has been known to
confuse beginners
a wiggled thumbs up means the number 10
in american sign language
while a flat palm under a thumbs up is
the sign for help
in the 1990s influential us movie
reviewers siskel and ebert used a thumbs
up or thumbs down rating system on their
tv show
they even trademarked the phrase two
thumbs up
now thumbs up and thumbs down signs are
everywhere on the internet
hoping for your approval
nor otherwise
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video